welcome everybody and thanks for
attending today we're going to talk
about some tools that you could use to
write larger shiny apps that are easy to
think about or to reuse shiny code
across apps and these tools are called
modules so let's start with the question
you what is a shiny module and
conceptually it's pretty easy to answer
a tiny module is a self-contained
composable component of a shiny app
self-contained means it's sort of like
an R function it does something and it
does it all by itself it might take some
input it might return some output but in
the middle of the process the app the
module doesn't need help from anything
else to come to do its job and because
of this shiny modules are composable you
could take multiple modules and pull
them together to make a shiny app and
probably the easiest way to understand
really where shiny app does and what it
looks like is to look at actual shiny
app that uses modules so let's go to our
studio what I have here is a single file
shiny app it makes this app over here
which is basically a recreation of hands
Rosling's Gapminder animations so what I
have is you know some different metrics
about all different countries on the
planet and particularly the life
expectancy those countries versus their
GDP and I have a slider down here that I
could play and it will show how things
have changed over time for these
different countries which which creates
a compelling story in its own way but
mostly I want to look at the app as it
is this app has a graph and a slider and
the two are connected in a way that you
could play the graph across time using
the slider in the app also several
different tabs if we look at any of the
tabs there just sub views of this data
so we get to look at countries on a
continent by continent basis except for
year final notes got on there we could
for any of these cots
we could play the animation and just see
you know how things change for African
countries for example or American
countries and if you think about the way
the app is designed there's a lot of
repetition here each tab each view does
the same thing it shows a graph and the
graph is connected to a slider the one
thing that's different between the
different views is the actual data set
that appears in the graph and if we come
over here and look at the code for the
app we see that you know pass because of
this there's a lot of repetition in the
code we do the same thing for each of
the different tabs on the server side we
have to recreate some more processes to
make the graph and connect it to the
slider there's reactive values in there
and it ends up being a fairly long app
and it's a little hard to find any
particular piece of code because there's
so much code to wade through but not
only that the code looks really similar
to other parts of the coding it's kind
of hard to be certain about where you're
at yeah now I've taken the time to
rewrite this app using shiny modules and
when you use modules the app looks like
this as much more concise it's much
smaller and what I've done is I've done
is I've written an R script that takes
the common pieces of code for each of
the tabs in our app and saves them the
functions so here in create a function
called gap module you I know a function
called gap module gap module does all
the server-side stuff to make that graph
connect to the slider and then in my
modulized
app i load that our script and instead
of calling you know visualize slider
here's what I want to graph here's what
I want them to connect I just call the
functions that do that for me so I'm
calling gap module six times once for
each view of the data and then I'm
calling you know the server side of gap
module six times once for each view of
the data this app is much easier to
understand as much easier to look at and
if I want to get in saying these
individual pieces and I could look at
the definition of gap module UI or gap
module over here so this is the
difference between a module wise DAP and
an app that's not much motorized once we
took the time to write our modules we
can recall them as many times as we want
so I've called gap module six times here
but I can also call it in a different
app so this is a great way to write some
code that you can reuse later on you
find for example you're always creating
some sort of upload API
in your apps you can create that API
once and then call that module across
all your apps and reuse it so that's
what modules are like conceptually
here's the here's our module in that
last app why would you use these modules
well you could see that it's very easy
to reuse this code modules are sorta
like functions once you take the time to
write them you could call them whenever
you like to redo whatever that function
does in this case what it does is create
components of Chania the next thing
about modules are that they really
isolate the functionality in your apps
once you write your module function all
you have to think about is what that
function does when you see it in your
app you don't have to think about how it
does what it does